oscar wilde once said that life imitates
art
far more than art imitates life this
seems especially true of the
establishment media
which often reads more like slam poetry
than journalism
if you attended a liberal arts college
if you have ever spent too much time in
a major city
you've likely heard of slam poetry well
now you can have
exactly the same experience when you
turn on cnn or when you read
the new york times i happen to be very
well versed in both left-wing journalism
and terrible left-wing art so i think
that i can bring my expertise to bear
and still tell the difference
but my producer thinks otherwise so i'm
going to take all my artistic
and journalistic skills and i'm going to
try to discern
whether random scraps of left-wing
claptrap
are woke poetry or broke journalism
before i begin i want to let you know
this video is sponsored by my american
hat
the best place to get patriotic hats
more from them later
but without further ado let us begin
breathe america donald trump's knee
is off your neck you rose
more than 75 million voters strong
and shoved him off your back the
debilitating weight that rendered you
helpless for
four agonizing years is no longer there
you are free now you survived
he thought he had convinced you that
living with a knee pinned to your neck
is not as bad as some make it out to be
he thought that you would be content to
remain under duress
for four more years
if he dangled a few distortions in your
face
still he thought he had you beaten he
thought he had drained every bit of
resilience
from your veins he thought you had given
up
he was sure he had won not only did you
free yourself
you liberated more than 70 million
others who voted to stay exactly
where they were some didn't even realize
there was a knee holding them down
okay this is a little tricky because
well i guess they're all kind of tricky
because
one giveaway for slam poetry is when
they just randomly start repeating words
you know like donald trump trump trump
put his knee on your back back on back
on knee you know like they do this kind
of stupid thing and they think it's
artistic so
this didn't have that which is a point
for its journalism but
because it it keeps going back to this
motif of the knee
on the neck and then obviously all the
other addiction i'm gonna say
that that was left-wing slam poetry
oh no it's gonna be a long it's gonna be
a long
test okay so this is from the chicago
tribune
this is a column the title is breathe
america donald trump's knee is
is off your neck and there it is you
rose more than 75 voter strong
wow yeah i was pretty confident i was
like 70 confident that was slam poetry
okay chicago tribune is i mean that's a
very left-wing paper all right let's
let's try again
james comey testifies before senate
while testifying before the senate fbi
director james comey made it abundantly
clear
russians interfered in the 2016
presidential election
there's no fuzz on that okay
shouldn't we all be up in arms nothing
to distract the facts besides the
problem at hand
when president trump fired comey last
month he said it was for the email
investigation though he later admitted
it was really russian allegations
labeling honesty
as misinformation his son-in-law tried
setting up a secret line of
communication undisclosed contacts
with another nation asian asian
undisclosed kind that's not even a full
sentence so that's a little bit more in
the poetry area
kushner flynn where does the truth begin
okay
you know i started this without thinking
this was definitely journalism but now
i'm not so sure
suspicion in the wind static in our
sleep
demanding our dreams unquestioned
loyalty
our country is full of no questions
please
huh this is tough because i would divide
this in half i would say if you asked me
about the first half i would say it's
definitely journalism
if you asked me about the second half i
would say it's definitely slam poetry
it's tough too because even the asian
asian rhyme it could just be
like really weak prose like really weak
journalism
i'm i'm still going to say journalism
really ah
man that's tricky because by the end
yeah play play do it his son-in-law
tried setting up a secret line of
communication
undisclosed contacts with another nation
kushner flynn
where does the truth begin wow
i just thought here's my defense i just
thought
it was so topical and specific
and stupid and ugly at the beginning
that no one not even a slam poet could
pretend that that was art
but i was wrong it was tricky that was a
very that was a tricky one
seems like everything is so unclear
these days everything is so up for
debate
are men women or babies people are riots
mostly peaceful very controversial
questions
but i hope that we can all agree on one
thing you should never be ashamed to be
an american
which is why you need to check out my
american hat started by a group of first
generation americans
my american hat looks to heal the social
fabric
by focusing on what we all should agree
on patriotism
should not be controversial whether you
are a republican or a democrat by
wearing my american hat
you demonstrate support for civilized
political discourse unity
and mutual respect more than just a
neatly designed hundred percent
american-made traditional baseball hat
my american hat is a symbol of unity of
our great nation
it's wonderful to buy american-made
products increasingly hard these days it
might get harder
depending on how this election turns out
a portion of the proceeds from my
american hat will be forwarded to the
charity fallen patriots which you can
find at fallenpatriots.org
this is a nonprofit organization created
to provide college scholarships
and educational counseling to military
children who have lost a parent in the
line of duty go check them out my
american hat
all right let's get into something very
un-american now more
broke journalism and woke poetry and
maybe the two will
conflate out of portland
tear gas an apparition emerges
she emerged as an apparition from clouds
of tear gas
as federal agents fired pepper balls at
angry protesters in the early saturday
darkness a woman wearing nothing but a
black
face mask and a stocking cap strode
toward a dozen heavily armed agents
attired in camouflage fatigues
she stood calmly a surreal image of
human vulnerability
in the face of an overpowering force
that has been criticized nationally
by civil rights advocates the agents
in gas masks and helmets continued
firing pepper balls in a staccato pop
pop aiming low at the asphalt
where puffs of smoke mingled with clouds
of gas
this actually is the best poetry that
i have seen from any slam poetry ever
however
i do know that this is journalism sort
of because i read it i remember reading
this article
and it's so insane and it's it's
terrible journalism
but it actually is probably the best
slam poetry i've ever heard
i knew it i know i got lucky on that one
because i already read it
wow okay cool snip snaps from me and
there she is that
i don't need to see that picture we can
we can we can take that picture off the
screen there is i already read the
article i don't no one needs to see that
an invitation to donald trump on behalf
of all mexican americans
you are right some of us are good people
you forget that in 1492 men like you
stole
our gold raped our women murdered our
children and labeled us as outsiders in
our homeland
before stealing the dirt beneath our
feet
tell me who really brought crime drugs
and rape to this country
there's so much to say here there's so
much to say i'll i'll restrain myself
until the end of
i guess a poem but we'll i'll we'll find
out at the end
don't forget we not only clean your
houses mow your lawn
pick your food cook your food serve your
food pave your roads we are
lawyers and professors doctors and
politicians teachers and students
priests and poets
so you're kind of tipping the hand our
grandparents built this empire
we are grandchildren of revolt the true
savages they forgot to burn
america is our home too and we will not
surrender man i didn't know the scottish
did all those things in america
gosh those scots man i thought it was
like the spaniards
maybe some italians okay they're going
after the scots i also love the idea
that there was no rape there was no
murder nothing like that in the
in the new world before the europeans
got here the aztecs didn't slaughter 80
000 people in four days at the
consecration of 10 octet line right no
they did okay
so it yeah i mean it reads it's it's
emotive
it's all very you know it's very
personal so in that way
it seems poetic but i i feel like i've
read things like this
in journalism like very similar things
like this in journalism over the past
few years
so i think the poetry here is a
misdirection i'm going to say
this is mainstream journalism
real
ah wow that's our grandparents built
this empire
we are grand children of the revolt the
true savages they forgot to burn
america is our home too and we will not
surrender yeah jim acosta is looking
great he's looking better than ever
okay well that's that was the
probably the hardest one yet
all right do we have any more is that it
i just lost
i just lost i got one i was one for
three it was only because i
or one for four one and three and it's
only because i had read that one before
that's that is really sad because i have
to say it's not i don't think it's just
that i'm really bad at this i've
actually sat through a lot of slam
poetry
which the literary critic harold bloom
once rightly called the death of art i
have listened to a lot of slam poetry i
have friends
who have performed slam poetry and i
have read a lot of journalism and i have
friends who are journalists that's
actually probably more embarrassing
than the friends who are slam poets i've
spent a lot of time on this and you
still can't tell
because they are they are one in the
same not just the death
of poetry but the death of journalism as
well